news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app for free
using the link right underneath this
video
i have breaking news about authoritarian
repression of the media for you
the president donald trump said
yesterday it should be
illegal for the news media to cover and
report
on the coronavirus pandemic when there's
an election about to happen
now as you may know we have more than
230 000 deaths in the u.s
from coronavirus we have one of the
highest per capita case rates in the
world
we have one of the highest per capita
death rates in the world
we have four percent of the population
and 20
of the deaths we are potentially heading
into the worst period for the u.s in
history
from the standpoint of public health and
it is imperative
that every american understand what's
going on rising cases
rising deaths what the stakes are and
what we must do
and trump wants it to be illegal for
news media
to report on a pandemic during a
pandemic
because he's trying to hide it so he can
get himself another four years in the
oval office
because he has failed miserably in
dealing with the virus trump tweeting
quote
we have made tremendous progress with
the china virus
but the fake news refuses to talk about
it this close to the election
kovidkovidkovid is being used by them
in total coordination in order to change
our great early election numbers should
be an election law
violation trump then complaining that
cnn
is talking about covid during one of his
three rallies yesterday take a look
you turn on cnn that's all they cover
kovetkovic pandemicov at covet cove and
you know why they're trying to talk
everybody out of voting people aren't
buying it cnn you
dumb bastards they're not
that's all they talk about
how delusional is this is this evil
is it sociopathic is it merely
dictatorial this
is happening in the middle of the united
states hitting new single day records
for cases over the weekend eighty one
thousand cases
on friday seventy nine thousand cases on
saturday
records we're in covid hell
in the united states and trump is saying
it should be
illegal for the news media to pick
stories
i thought this guy was against
regulation i thought this guy was about
letting everybody do what they want to
do and
stopping oppressive government
intervention it should be illegal
to report on the pandemic and
it's also even funnier because to the
extent any of this is funny
it should be against election law trump
says the media
should be bound by election law in what
they can cover they're not even running
for anything election law typically
applies
to candidates to campaigns and to donors
textbook fascism this is a lunatic
wannabe dictator now news
about a hundred year pandemic should be
against the law trump says
biden should be in jail but he won't
tell us what crimes were committed
he says he will lock up the bidens trump
has been putting pressure on william
barr to investigate the bidens
trump won't commit to a peaceful
transfer of power
but i don't think it will work anyway in
the sense of
trying to suppress the fact that 230 000
realistically 310
000 if you actually look at excess
mortality
hundreds of thousands of people needless
to say have died on his watch
trying to suppress it i don't think will
make people forget about it and i don't
think it will make people
forgive donald trump not the same
rational people anyway
although there's plenty of outrageous
people around as well
but the most important thing to debunk
here is the idea that kovid
had to be bad for politicians it's been
horrible for the world as far as tragedy
and death
and suffering but politically it's only
bad if you mishandle it
new zealand's president was re-elected
in a landslide
because she successfully kept the
pandemic under control she also happens
to be a normal person who's not
completely out of touch with reality
so trump could be sailing to reelection
if he had handled this correctly serious
question to conservatives
do you support trump's statement that
it should be against the law for the
news to report on a pandemic
because there's an election close by
seems indefensible
and yet i'm continuously surprised by
what the right is willing to support
should the media be banned from
discussing covid
close to an election the majority of
trumpists i'm seeing online now these
are just the ones willing to comment
online
there could be a vast silent majority
that is against this
but what i'm seeing online from
trumpists is uh it was taken out of
context
um it uh trump only said it as a joke
uh the media should be banned from
covering it because they lie about it if
they told the truth they should be
allowed to cover it but because the fake
news media is
lying about the pandemic they shouldn't
be allowed to cover it
i want to hear from trumpists do you
agree with this should it be illegal
to cover coronavirus i'm on twitter at
deepakman
let me know